Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David,
here's a great little voicemail. Caller's mom
watches the show on tick tock. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Hi, David. Ryan here from Iowa. I. I
just went home to visit my. Quite elderly mother
and. I noticed she was watching you on tick tock.
When I came in, I thought I recognized your voice.
After. That was pact. She said she had
to go back. I told her I subscribe to
you and I pay for that promise. So. Oh. The
bonus show where you want to make money.
Yeah. Everybody else who makes money to fund
themselves is bad. Right. You're great. I just
thought I'd share that with you. I thought
it was quite interesting. Thank you.
Speaker 1: You know, super interesting. We're
all aware of all of the problems with Tick
Tock as a platform. This has nothing to do
with that in terms of Tick Tock as a place
to get our message out, because we're using
the tools where there is an audience. The
growth we have seen on Tick Tock is wild. And
even though Tick Tock audiences skew younger,
overall, we have not only a young audience
on Tick Tock, like in the 13 to 13 to 24,
which is a little younger than like our
core audience, which is like 24 to 54.
We also have a sizable 65 plus audience on
Tick Tock. Just the other day at a pharmacy,
an older woman came up to me and said, I
watched, you're the guy from Tick Tock. So
listen, the tick tock regulation stuff is going to
get sorted out as a platform. It has been a huge
place to get our message out. At this point,
I think I'm getting recognized as much for
being on tick tock as being on YouTube. And it's
beautiful to hear this heartwarming message from
the caller. Okay, great bonus show for you today.
The military COVID vaccine mandate may be ending
and it might be Biden doing it. I thought
he was just going to do all mandates. Well,
apparently not. We will talk about the EU allowing
phone calls on flights. Why aren't phone calls
allowed on flight? Why aren't phone calls allowed
on flights? We will talk about it. And also, New
Zealand plans a law to require Facebook and Google
to pay for news to pay who? What does that mean?
We will talk about all of it on today's bonus
show. You can sign up at join Katherine Scott.